hello everyone and welcome to the last
day of the video World Cup regardless of
what happens today we end it and we will
have a winner so the first two classical
games ended in a draw and now we have a
tie breaks between pregnant and Magnus
cross and Prague will have the wine
pieces in the first game so as uh you
know throughout the entire cup they will
have two games of uh rapid uh uh chess
with 25 minutes per player then if those
get drawn uh then we have a 10 minutes
per player rapid game so if those get
drawn then we get five minutes per
player those are Blitz Games uh and if
it does get drawn we go not into
Armageddon we go into sudden death which
means three minutes per player uh plus
two seconds increment until one of the
player players win so it could go on
forever but you know uh we actually hope
it does so let's uh dive straight into
it Prague has the white pieces in first
game and he opens with Ponte E4 we have
Pawn to E5 by Magnus Knight F3 Knight to
C6 and Bishop to C4 the Italian game is
on the board uh Knight to F6 going for
the two nice defense and now not Knight
to G5 which you all are hoping for Ponte
D3 the so-called modern Bishop's opening
with Bishop to C5 and now Pawn to A4
Knight the G5 is a nice idea but uh of
course try and get against Magnus uh
probably nothing good will come from it
so best uh you know stick to the
classics the D6 with castles and Ponte
A5 Magnus stops the future B4 uh we have
Bishop to E3 and here at Magnus trades
and the doubles up approx um uh Central
e pawns and but okay it probably does
get the semi-openf file for his rook and
there will be constant pressure on this
F7 Pawn
uh so here we have castles uh and the
Knight beat the D2 and here we have
Knight the E7 and already now as of move
nine we have a completely new game so uh
Prague decides to stop Knight to G6 he
goes Knight to the H4 and now while it
seems like a good idea to actually trade
off this knight uh after captures and
captures uh this other Knight will come
to F3 and once this Knight comes to G5
there's no way to kick it away from
there and then you'll have this constant
pressure of The Rook attacking F7 the
bishop attacking F7 and denied attacking
F7 and you will not have the H Pawn to
kick it away from there so that's why
after H6 Magnus goes C6 we have a pawn
to D5 coming next uh Queen to E1 by
Prague preparing Queen to G3 to go after
magnus's King and pawn to D5 with Bishop
back to B3 and now Queen to D6 this is a
very important move because once the
queen lands on G3 the thread of Rook
captures and F3 uh will be paired by
just uh you know the queen being on D6
so here we have Queen to G3 and now
Knights the H5 and Magnus really took a
time to think about this next move and
yeah it's not easy to develop because
like I said I move like a bishop D6
might sound useful but it runs into Rook
captures on F6 you have to have your
queen defending the Knight here so
instead Knight H5 attacks prox Queen
and the product could go for something
like Queen to F3 and we might even see a
drawback repetition here with something
like this but instead after Knight H5
progress Queen to G5 he keeps the
tension and keeps the queen into the
attack and now Magnus should go back
with Knight to F6 but he uh says Nope my
knight is perfectly fine there I'm gonna
play G6 and then I'm gonna play F6 kick
away your queen and the proc should
actually allow this he should play
Knights to F3 and the ones F6 is played
Queen H4 and okay you uh at least you
ruined the black's King side a little
bit but he doesn't go for that after
this G6 move he goes for Knight to F5
right away and okay let's see what
happens here Magnus is all right Bishop
captures on F5 e captures on F5 and now
King to G7 you have to stop uh Pawn to
F6 so King to G7 now the queen and uh
King nicely guard the F6 square and the
king the H1 and here now Prague probably
missed a very important Tempo in order
to keep the attention uh something like
Rook 81 should have been better I
actually have no idea Awakening the H1
was played probably to get off the king
from this diagonal for some reason I
mean Prague is obviously an incredibly
strong player he knows why he did it I
cannot you know Enlighten you in in any
way of why he did it but okay we have
Queen to F6 by Magnus now he takes
advantage of um Prague playing such a
slow move and progno has to trade or go
move back with Queen to G4 but then
Knight captures an F5 happens and you're
gonna have a worse position so you have
to trade Queens here Queen captures we
have Knight captures and F6 now F
captures and g6h captures and pawn to E4
uh Magnus trades here the captors and
proc doesn't want to trade Knight so he
plays D captors on e4 and the Knight is
uh very good very nicely placed here and
now you see how Rook 81 probably would
have been better in that position
because all of this wouldn't be so
appealing to Magnus because now uh the
pawn would be defended the next move you
could simply go for Knight C4 put
pressure on E5 and the A5 so before
doing this now you're gonna have to
defend the on so Rook 8 to d8 Magnus now
stops rotate the D1 as the Knight here
is hanging and the product just goes
Rook to F2 he says I don't mind uh I
actually uh probably even wanted to play
this because now my other Rook is coming
to F1 and I will have this incredible
pressure on the F7 pawn and Magnus has
to choose between two ideas or rather
more more ideas but the The crucial one
seems to be nice to see it inviting Rook
8 to F1 and now after Knight G4 you go
into this very tricky line of actually
giving up the F7 Pawn sorry Rook
captures and F7 real captors Rook
captures now King comes to H6 and now
you have to do something about your
Knight hanging so Knight to F1 and now
Knight the D6 attacks the rook and
defends the B7 pawn and once this Rook
moves now you capture on e4 and now you
have to accidentally Place Knights your
other your Rook is coming to D1 so this
is the the active way to play this but
Magnus did not go for this he went for
Rook to D4 he just puts pressure on the
E4 pawn and fragos for Rook 8 to F1 he
says alright if you move your knight I'm
just gonna start capturing an F7 so we
have Knight E to G8 and now we have Pawn
to C3 kicking away The Rook Rook goes
back to D7 and now Rook to E2 now the
pawn is sufficiently defended and the
Knight can move with Rook to E7 and
sorry uh Rook D7 and now Bishop to C2 we
have knighted the D7 and now Knight to
C4 finally prog's Knight gets to this
active square and Magnus is forced to go
back with the Rook so Rook the A8
defends the pawn and now Pawn to G4 proc
stops any any expansion here and the
Magnus plays Pawn to F6 with Rook to G2
now and Knight the H6 putting pressure
on the pawn here and Prague just goes
for it pawn to G5 we have F characters
and G5 Rook captures now the G6 Pawn
might be a little bit weak if Brock can
uh get those Rooks targeted at the pawn
and Knight the F7 chases away The Rook
Rook to G2 and now Rook the E6 The Rook
will now nicely defend the Pawn here uh
both Prague and Magnus are now under
three minutes uh so it's gonna be uh
very very difficult to play this Rook to
D2 Pro goes after the night here uh Rook
to F6 uh defending by attacking as Now
The Rook on F1 is hanging Rook captures
an F6 Knight captures on F6 and now proc
finally blasts through with Pawn to B4
uh and okay eight characters mb4c
capture some B4 and now King to f8 so
now uh Prague will have to try to push
those pawns on the queen side whereas
Magnus will have to try to activate
those Knights if he can get his Rook
somehow on the second rank or or
somewhere and he can activate the
knights then it's gonna be good for him
if not uh proxy Bishop should be very
very strong so King G2 with King t7 and
now Pawn to A5 we have Rook back to h8
and now Rook to E2 uh here we have
Knight to H5 and now King to G1 we have
Knight to a four Magnus slowly but
surely activating those Knights Rook to
D2 and now comes Rook to H3 and here uh
program was already down to a few
seconds on the clock and Magnus was
still up up a few minutes and proc
should just play a waiting move there's
really no active move for Prague here he
cannot Advance the pawns there's no good
Square for the Knight he he should play
Bishop to D1 and just wait and then he
can play King to F1 and wait it is
definitely uh Magnus who's running the
show here but he went for the active
move Ponte A6 uh yeah the the pressure
got to him and now Magnus simply
captured we have Bishop to A4 going
after the C6 pawn and now Rook the C3 by
Magnus you could also just take
advantage of the weird placement of the
king and Rook by playing Knight to G5
it's a free Tempo going for F3 but
Magnus first place a rook to C3
attacking the Knight and now Prague
still has a chance to fight with Rook to
C2 but proc played Knight's day 5 just
went for the C6 pawn and now the
position is completely winning for
Magnus and he doesn't squander it Magnus
plays Knight to G5 now threatening the
fork with Knight to F3 uh we have rooked
the C2 offering a rook trade but now
Knight Gita H3 with check King to F1 and
now Rook the A3 and you can see that the
knights are controlling these three
squares so now Prague has to choose
between a bishop and Checkmate on A1 he
delivers one more check Knight captures
on C6 Magnus just moves away the king
and he was in this position and move 47
that pragnananda resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
now you will either lose the bishop or
you are getting checkmated there is no
way to play this so of course Prague
resigns this so what this means is that
now uh Prague will have to defeat Magnus
with the black pieces in the second game
of the Rapids if he wants to force more
tie breaks um if he wants to force the
the 10-minute rapid tie breaks so we'll
see what happens I of course I'm always
up for more games but it's not going to
be easy as Magnus will now be having the
white pieces and if Magnus doesn't want
to lose with white uh it is going to be
very hard uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it I will uh you
know inform you on what happens in game
two uh so stay tuned for that I would
like to thank Franz pan card Brendan
Mathis samiron gosh
and Robert Bloom for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon like I
said with the second game of the tie
breaks uh so you know stay tuned for
that thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day